uh we got another story um let's uh
let's jump over the next story let's get
into it
oh yeah this our next segment has me
worried me too
this one's a pop-culture e who did Sam
room what did he do again so hold on sam
raimi in talks to direct dr. strange to
exclusive from variety and so actually
we'll go back and talk about what's
going on but they lost their director oh
the original one is gone the original
doctor departed is that the one that was
that did the first dr. strange
I think cuz I liked that movie no no I I
don't I don't necessarily know maybe I
think so
okay but I know that what will read this
they're saying creative differences and
now they might tap Sam Raimi and that
has me worried wait what did he do those
examining you like eated spider-man and
I think the first one like that like the
og spider-man movies I'm pretty sure
that was him if I'm getting this wrong
then you are allowed to send me hate
mail I did not like those is it heated
spider-man right the new spider-man can
you is awesome the new ones are great
all the new ones are awesome yeah those
but I'm not trying to rag them he's got
a huge fan base and like on reddit has
he done anything good though that you
know he did the Evil Dead yes okay Evil
Dead I mean it's a little outdated now
have you seen it lately okay drag me to
heck that was not bad dark man Wow so
like horror flicks that's why they're
tapping him yeah but where are you
saying that this is gonna be it was
supposed it's supposed to be yeah Doctor
Strange to is supposed to be like horror
that's kind of cool that's yeah and I
like the villain is supposed to be
potentially nightmare which is like okay
nightmare demon yeah you nightmares or
whatever well let's let's do this a
little bit cool so Doctor Strange to
director drops out scott derrickson hmm
this is from last month but I think if
we're gonna talk about Sam Urick what's
Sammy's gonna pick up yeah I really want
to talk about Doctor Strange because it
is my favorite movie to us well I'd say
so
absolutely yeah out of the MCU universe
or my favorite movie I have I have I
would say that's a big bull Damon that's
not sure anymore
the Joker is Joker is my favorite movie
right now I can't I can't think of
anything better than Joker right now
that's a good movie you're right it's
killer oh no you know you know what you
know what let me just step back and say
it is it is
unfair for me to say any of these things
are my favorite movies why well Joker
was amazing yeah doctor she is
definitely my favorite MCU for sure and
top interesting but 1917 man you saw it
it's amazing really I'm really good
amazing amazing that's cool yeah sad sad
oh it's sad yeah so let's let's let's
see what's going on with mr. dr. strange
now that I'll tell you this one of the
main reasons I want to talk about this
is because I as I said I love dr.
strange the first movie is awesome and
we'll go through this one quickly to get
to the updated news by the in context is
relevant they say scott derrickson is
stepping down as director of Marvel's
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness the studio confirmed his
departure in a statement attributing it
to creative differences derrickson who
oversaw the first Doctor Strange will
remain in as executive producer well
that's good that that's great Marvel
Studios and scott derrickson have
amicably parted ways on Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness due to
creative differences
Marvel said in a statement to variety we
remain grateful to Scott for his
contributions to the MCU derrickson also
said the decision was mutual Marvel and
I have mutually agreed to part ways on
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness due to creative differences I am
thankful for our collaboration and will
remain on as ep the film will begin
production in May and they and their are
not expected to be any delays when it
comes to shooting the search for a
replacement is currently underway
they say Doctor Strange was a critical
and commercial success when it opened in
2016 grossing nearly 680 million
globally the sequel will find Benedict
Cumberbatch returning estranged a master
of the mystic arts Elizabeth Olsen who
plays Scarlet Witch is also expected to
appear in the film scheduled for release
for release May 7th 2021 you know I'm
really bummed about hmm you know by May
I think I think the the entire collapse
of the nation will have already happened
if it Trump's re-election and there's
pitchforks and fires in the street so
maybe we'll never get to see it you know
and a lot of people like Trump though I
mean I don't think they think it's gonna
be that big I'm just gonna happen now
there's gonna be great there's gonna be
a lot of crazy people they're not crazy
thing great crazy things but I'm kidding
let's get back to Doctor Strange a lot
of people already groaning being like
talk about Marvel Tim so it's Sam Raimi
okay I'll say you look if they're gonna
do
I mean if it's dark and and and they
want to
kind of uh I think he might actually be
good for this because if you think about
what evil bed is yeah it is comedy
horror right and Marvel is supposed to
be more upbeat right and so they want to
do a horror thing but Spider Man was not
horror I mean at all but is it I mean
look cheesy corny wannabe comic book II
but it failed I few no no no yes the
spider-man movies made good money sure
they've been a money okay and I weren't
very good but you know no no no hold on
man I think I think you're judging
spider-man in the past based on the
standards of the MCU today you're right
I absolutely I would say I would say if
it weren't for Raimi and spider-man we
wouldn't have the great MCU that we do
today because you got to stand on the
shoulders of a giant you know I mean I
can't I can't deny that you're right
it's so like sense if I go back in time
I'm not I'm not like have you ever seen
this is the end which one's uh it's
called this is the end no and it's like
James Franco and Seth Rogen and Craig
Robinson and they're all friends oh and
the J's open up in the ground yeah like
it's the apocalypse yeah but they're but
they're like making fun of Franco for
having a Green Goblin money like Cassie
was Green Goblin yeah look you've got
that Green Goblin money man anyway look
look maybe it was just cuz I was a lot
younger but I enjoyed spider-man for
that was back then did three and I
watched him and spider-man three
disappointed me even back then yeah and
today spider-man the MCU they're amazing
so that's why I'm worried
I like venom a lot so spider-man three
was like man no no no I'm not talking
about the movie I like the color yeah no
sure absolutely
like I've always liked venom so when I
saw that movie it was like ah man it
just didn't feel right you know didn't
feel right I think Topher Grace does a
good job in a lot of roles and guy but
venom yeah exactly
so are we I wouldn't feel it but are we
really oh I can't believe having this
conversation about a movie from all that
mm was it six or something yeah well Tom
Hardy kills it Tom Hardy was great and I
wasn't
I thought Woody Harrelson's come in as
do me also I can't wait and they're
bringing Andy Serkis on to direct I'm
pretty sure
so I'm excited for look I think Sony's
watched a bunch of movies Morbius is
coming out I hope that's good look so
worried dude are you I'm worried man
because Sony Boches a lot of things
venom did really well monetarily but
sony sony i liked it a lot and I thought
it was okay I thought it was good I was
I was I would actually give it a c-minus
maybe the D plus I'd give it a solid B
really mm-hmm
yeah I think they could have done way
better it had you know it had a kind of
I don't know generic feel to it I can't
put my finger on it like why the my
Marvel Studios hits the nail on the head
so often like even even in the wasp
which is not the best movie I've ever
seen yeah yeah I compaq give it like a
c-minus I know what it is it's the bad
guy it's the bad guy in venom it's just
like these dry it's done before it's
yeah it's like oh cool it's the evil
scientist dude trying to like you know
just yeah he wasn't written well yeah
yeah that's what it was everything else
about that movie was great but I could
see that that was a little stale I think
that's I think you I think you nailed it
yeah Tom Hardy was amazing you know what
you know what you know the best villain
is hmm I think the best film they've
ever done is vulture and spider-man is
that Michael Michael Keenan he's good
you know why he was the best villain
it's relatable yeah it was a real like a
real villain yeah yeah it's like so many
of these villains are like I'm blue and
you're like that's your motivation you
just want to kill people here yeah but
this was a guy and they show you right
away he's like please don't destroy my
company I've got families to feed and
they're like we don't care about you and
so you really you kind of feel for him
this dude's a tough guy and he's gonna
stop at nothing to protect his friends
at his family his motivations aren't
evil yeah he just has reckless disregard
for those around him and the
consequences of his actions he sees a
bad guy
well how about Joker it's like okay by
the end of that movie I felt I felt for
Jo fell for Joker more like I did peen I
liked
Joker more than Batman and I used to
love Batman and like after that movie
I'm like Oh Batman but Joker yeah it's
crazy to me feel for Joker like man I
get it bro I get it
it's you do you Joker but it kind of
shooting someone in the face like what
spoiler alert but it's kind of crazy to
me that sorry if you haven't unit you
actually the story of this dude who's
mentally ill mm-hmm he's you know
struggles to find work you know he's
underemployed low wages the city cuts
his benefits all of these really
horrible things and he finally snaps and
you don't agree with what he does right
but you understand why he when he snaps
and yeah and it doesn't mean you condone
it and so many people in the media were
like this is a film to rally in shells
and all this other insanity and it's
like oh if you can't empathize with
somebody who's suffering and and the
city's callousness when they're like
work and you know the woman says to him
they don't care about people like you
and me yeah and then they invite him on
TV to make fun of him and belittle him
it's like dude these these these shows
know this like look at American Idol
it's the best way to explain it they
know these people are not bright or
unwell and they would bring them on and
make them look bad on TV on purpose you
know because they're terrible singers
and they're like all this is perfect I
feel like we took the worse than the
best right I felt we should get back to
Sam Raimi sure yeah but anyway I'll
write that up basic yeah basically when
it comes to American Idol my
understanding was they would
purposefully take people who are bad
singers and bet you can come in and good
singers would be pushed out because they
didn't care if you're a good singer they
care if your story would do well on TV
right exact so when you see those bad
singers it's all orchestrated to mock
and belittle you yeah well so anyway
let's see
they say sam raimi who helped launch the
modern superhero movie with 2002
spider-man is in talks to direct Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of multiverse
of madness for Marvel he'll replace
scott derrickson but Marvel had no
comment we'll skip over that stuff after
finishing a spider-man trilogy for
Sony's with 2007's spider-man three
Raimi's output as a director's slowed
considerably with just the horror pic
dragged me to heck in 2009 I kid you not
we can't say that word I'm not kidding
YouTube will like we're probably in
trouble but you know but whatever
YouTube so insane and Disney's The
Wizard of Oz capable he did it he did
the Oz the great and powerful
in 2013 never saw and said he's been
busy as a producer helping relaunch
various horror franchises like
poltergeist and his own classic Evil
Dead did you have anything do it that
show ash vs. Evil Dead cuz that was
pretty good was it
good yeah I mean I didn't watch all of
it I watched some of it mmm Diddy it's
set in the Evil Dead universe it looks
like you might have had out like a cameo
in it I don't think you did mmm that's
Bruce Campbell right I like it yeah yeah
he's cool he's funny so they go on and
just save a lot of base basically the
same things Oh Rachel McAdams will not
reply's reprise her role that kind of
bums me out she was pretty cool
you know it's interesting so originally
I guess this was reported that it was
like definitive they put out a tweet
saying it was like confirmed but it's
not confirmed so look man has confirmed
that he was gonna direct it okay I I
love Doctor Strange I did a great story
they don't mess it up it's a story about
a guy who goes from being an arrogant
narcissist but who has great talent yeah
and then he has like you know a
reckoning with with what life really is
and I love the scene where he's asked by
Mort out how did you even do that how
did you how do you even know the litany
of spells required to perform that you
know and he says I have photographic
memory you know it's how I got my MD and
PhD at the same time and I like the idea
it's one of the reasons I like Iron Man
I like Batman and and MCU has done this
a lot like a lot of the heroes in the
MCU are just people with tech yeah so
like Captain America sure he's a
superhuman yeah
war machine Falcon Iron Man just people
with tech mm-hmm Doctor Strange just the
dude who studied really hard I really do
like music arts but for sure but but
what I mean is there's there's something
I like a lot better about somebody who
earns their write their power okay
instead of like a lot of mutants who are
like I can shoot lasers I got bit by a
radioactive spider and now I'm
spider-man
yeah so you know cool you earned it
buddy but but it's interesting I think
ability I think you know I don't know
you'd explain Thor he's an alien I guess
he's God whatever in Asgard
but there but a lot of I was thinking
about this I was like man a lot of the
characters scarlet I'm not a scribe
Black Widow Hawkeye just people and you
know straight of people Captain America
has technically just a dude but he's got
like Super Soldier Serum or whatever
yeah but that's why I like Doctor
Strange so you know I guess we'll see
what happens with this story but yeah I
really hope they don't mess but whether
or not it's super relevant I thought it
was a good way you know to talk about
what we're gonna see with the film and
what's going on but um
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you